the president tweeted this morning that
the FBI and Justice Department will
review what he calls the outrageous
Jesse smollett case that follows an
angry response to the dropping of all
charges against the Empire actor who was
accused of staging a hate crime against
himself Adriana Diaz is in Chicago
following the continuing controversy
Adriana good morning good morning late
yesterday we spoke to one of some
alleged attorneys who is outraged by
city officials conducting what she calls
a campaign against the actor but there
is plenty of outrage to go around here
in Chicago the mayor is still furious
that the charges were dropped and the
top prosecutor whose office made that
decision is doubling down we spoke with
her too as calls for a federal
investigation loom over the case against
actor Jesse Smollett Chicago's top
prosecutor Kim Fox is defending her
staffs decision to drop charges against
the Empire actor the nature of this case
suggested that he was eligible for an
alternative prosecution
there's eligible that's optional it's
also could have moved forward and tried
to go to trial with him we could have
Fox recused herself from the
investigation shortly before Smollett
was charged in February because she'd
spoken to one of his relatives after the
alleged incident well I didn't want
knowing that that the investigation to
have any questions or doubts about my my
handling of the case emails obtained by
the Chicago Tribune show Fox tried to
get police to turn the investigation
over to the FBI after Tina Chen a
smollett family friend and former chief
of staff to first lady Michelle Obama
reached out to Fox with concerns from
smollett's family about the police
investigation people come to me on cases
regularly regularly it doesn't add up as
I said yesterday nothing here adds up
Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel still stunned
by the decision to abandon charges
against mullet wants a clearer
resolution to the case in the city of
Chicago deserves an answer and they
deserve an answer about accountability
and responsibility in the system
early Tuesday Chicago Police released
documents outlining how they built what
they can
an ironclad case the 61 pages of
detectives reports reveal details of the
connection between Smollett and the
oaths and IRA brothers who told police
he hired them to help orchestrate a fake
hate crime including giving them a
hundred dollars to purchase rope masks
and hats according to one report after
testifying before a grand jury one
brother said it felt good that he told
the truth
Smollett claims a $3,500 check was for
fitness training according to the
documents at their maximum rate of $50
per hour that check would have paid for
71 hour training sessions
that's what Jesse's always paid
previously for training Smollett legal
team maintains the actor is innocent
other than the self-serving statements
by the two brothers nothing actually
connects Jesse to the attack a former
lawyer for those two brothers who were
involved maintains their innocence now
minutes after Chicago police released
those detective supports they were
ordered by a judge to seal them lawyers
for the press including CBS News have
filed motions to keep those documents
are being destroyed and to make them
public Gayle Adriana Diaz a lot of
questions still in that case I think
Adriana said it best at the beginning
there's enough outrage to go around
people on all sides are trying to figure
out what is a real story and everybody
thinks there is more to this story than
well as the mayor said it just doesn't
add up
investigation is certainly under way
there